ah non mais ce lait apeuré aux abois
c'est ainsi qu'apparaît Samuel Paty ce
professeur d'histoire sauvagement
assassiné en 2020 à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine quelques jours
à peine avant sa mise à mort c'est le
Parisien qui révèle dans son édition de
l'indice et nouveaux éléments de
l'enquête tel qu'ils apparaissent dans
leur rapport des policiers nourrit de
témoignages inédits et de l'historique
des recherches effectuées par le
professeur quelques jours avant sa mort
plusieurs de ses collègues racontent
notamment l'état de stress et de tension
dans lequel il se trouvait pour leur 14
personnes complices d'abdoulah controv
parmi lesquels des collégiens qui ont
désigné Samuel Paty au tueur contre de
l'argent et le parodie d'élève
d'ailleurs absente du cours de Samuel
Paty ainsi qu'un militant islamiste figé
s responsable de la campagne de haine
contre l'enseignant sont mises en examen
mais ces nouveaux éléments qui ajoutent
comme l'écrivent les policiers que c'est
l'action combinée de ces protagonistes
impliqués à des degrés divers mais tous
indiff aux conséquences néfastes de
leurs actes qui aura conduit à
l'assassinat ces nouveaux éléments donc
pourraient nourrir la plainte pour
non-existence à personne en danger et
non empêchement de crime qu'on déposer
des membres de la famille de Samuel Paty
car c'est bien là que se situe le fond
de l'affaire Samuel Paty a bénéficié de
quelques soutiens de ses collègues mais
pas de tout de se tient de sa principale
mais pas de toute la hiérarchie de
l'éducation nationale et en tout cas il
a été laissé seul sans protection face à
un déferlement de haine qu'on a accusé à
tort d'avoir déclenché faire la lumière
sur ces manquements serait non seulement
rendre justice à Samuel Paty mais aider
aussi tous ses collègues qui se heurtent
aux atteintes de plus en plus répandus à
la laïcité